ladies and gentlemen Spielberg
well in a moment one of these ten movies
will join a list that includes on the
waterfront Midnight Cowboy the Godfather
and the deer hunter the other nine will
join a list that includes The Grapes of
Wrath Citizen Kane the graduate and
Raging Bull
either way congratulations your own very
good company here now are your 10 best
pictures of the year and the nominees
for Best Motion Picture are Black Swan
the fighter inception
The Kids Are Alright
The King's Speech 127 hours the social
network Toy Story 3 True Grit Winter's
Bone
and the Oscar goes to the King's Speech
rien que me and Neil Sherman and Gareth
the King speech has 12 Academy
or nominations this year winning four
Oscars for original screenplay directing
lead actor and Best Picture
Wow what an incredible incredible honor
and what an amazing year for film it to
be with those other films in that
category is just absolutely incredible
um Tom Hooper you put so much passion
and love into every frame of this film
oh sorry there Thank You directing the
film to our acting royalty Colin Jeffrey
Helena thank you so much for saying yes
to our amazing best of British crew it's
so amazing to share the stage with you
tonight and to my parents and to my
boyfriend Ben you helped me every day do
what I do
thank you we've been part of her we've
been part of a film that's touched a
muth people so much all around the world
has been just a huge privilege and we
indebted to everyone standing behind us
and you know our finances took a huge
risk on this film is not an obvious film
to to back to our distribution partners
The Weinstein Company Harvey and Bob
Weinstein momentum Pictures and
transmission films with your passion and
commitment to this film the UK film
Council Aegis Film Fund Mullen air film
nation thank you to all our finance ears
and personally to my wife Caroline and
my parents Brian and Jean for your love
and support
my little boys Milo Zack and sigh thank
you so much thank you all I'll be really
really quick so just a massive thank you
to the UK film Council for supporting
this film and David Seidler for trusting
us with his heartfelt story Rosie I love
you Simon for thank you first of all to
me over the years but mostly Thank You
Academy this is a boyhood ambition come
true tonight